four million more people
got their first shot in august than they
did in july
but we need to do more
this is not about freedom
or personal choice
it's about protecting yourself and those
around you the people you work with
the people you care about the people you
love
my job as president is to protect all
americans
so tonight
i'm announcing that the department of
labor
is developing an emergency rule
to require all employers
with 100 or more employees
that together employ over 80 million
workers
to ensure their workforces
are fully vaccinated
or show a negative test at least once a
week
some of the biggest companies are
already requiring this
united airlines
disney
tyson's food
and even fox news
the bottom line
we're going to protect vaccinated
workers from unvaccinated co-workers
we're going to reduce the spread of
covet 19 by increasing the share of the
workforce that is vaccinated in
businesses all across america
my plan will extend the vaccination
requirements
that i previously issued in the health
care field
already i've announced we'll be
requiring vaccinations at all nursing
home workers
who treat patients on medicare and
medicaid because i have that federal
authority
tonight i'm using that same authority
to expand that to cover those who work
in hospitals
home health care facilities or other
medical facilities
a total of 17 million health care
workers
if you're seeking care
at a health facility you should be able
to know
that the people treating you are
vaccinated simple straightforward period
next
i will sign an executive order
that will now require all executive
branch federal employees to be
vaccinated all
i've signed another executive order that
will require federal contractors
to do the same
if you want to work with the federal
government and do business with us get
vaccinated
if you want to do business with the
federal government vaccinate your
workforce
and tonight
i'm removing one of the last remaining
obstacles that make it difficult for you
to get vaccinated
the department of labor will require
employers with 100 or more workers
to give those workers paid time off to
get vaccinated
no one should lose pay
in order to get vaccinated or take a
loved one to get vaccinated
today
in total
the vaccine requirements in my plan will
affect about 100 million americans
two-thirds of all workers